you smell nice you too ya know
[Music]
hi my name is Kramer Cruz hello my name
is Cara Anthony we have been together
for about a year just over a year and as
the relationship got more serious
obviously she wanted you know more and
more commitment I just wasn't really
ready to do that when I signed up for
this and decided to do this game I
thought oh it'll be fine
like we're still cool like we can work
together but actually the anxiety that
has come about doing this today is a
little overwhelming like it's a little
somber hey my name is Quinn knocks hi
I'm Leo Velez we dated for I guess about
six months things got a little too
comfortable and we just I don't know
decided that it was best not to see each
other anyone we were very mature about
it
so we talked it out and we agree we
tried to make it work but you know once
the fire is gone kinda hard to be
ignited that's something like I think
should come naturally up to like at
least keep in my life because I mean
Quinn's a great guy to have them
involved would be a great thing he's
like someone I'd really value I don't
understand exactly why it broke off I
don't think he does either but just I'm
open for new experiences it's all coming
back to me now Jake we can just leave
your shoes I'm like OCD
conservatives start okay oh okay good
that's easy
oh no spider-man just to keep this one
up I'll push you over oh yeah that's the
the role of dissent like I'm doing yoga
yeah your site dashing away from I did
not deal with this inspired spider
Manish okay yeah I knew I was gonna win
yeah thank God
I don't know that we're gonna be playing
anymore twister we get very competitive
with each other and I think that was one
of the problems maybe but ah I don't
know it was kind of nice
I mean it's um keeps you on your toes I
think it's difficult you know with
relationships like how you move forward
if you stay if it can continue or if it
just breaks off and so I don't know for
me this confirmed that we still have
good chemistry regardless of whatever
happens in the future like in the
beginning you know I felt some rigidness
you know like you know was awkward with
the silence and everything but as we got
into the game you know something about
the game the atmosphere of the game at
all kind of like lowered my guard a
little bit you know I mean I'd like to
think that just being here today and
like having this experience could open
the doors for us to just even like talk
about it after this congratulations for
winning oh thank you
[Music]